Alabama Senate candidate Morrie Moore
says he's going to take off the gloves
with two weeks left in the campaign
Moore made his first public appearance
in 11 days at a rally last night he
denies allegations of groping and
pursuing teenage girls including a 14
year old decades ago outside members of
Moore's team confronted reporters
covering the rally at one point as you
see in the campaign an official shoved a
camera man
mark Strassmann is in Fort Payne Alabama
where the rally was held mark good
morning good morning room wars campaign
has yet to comment about what was going
on with that cameraman and Moore has
spent much of the last couple of weeks
avoiding questions about his alleged
sexual misbehavior four decades ago but
two supporters he had a lot to say about
200 supporters breeded Roy Moore with a
standing ovation we've seen malicious
and false attacks which reflect the
immorality of our time
Moore again denied he ever made unwanted
sexual advances to teenage girls when he
was in his 30s this is simply dirty
politics on Monday more released a new
television ad but four weeks before the
election false allegations saying the
accusations were quote a scheme by
liberal elites and the Republican
establishment it's no different than
when the Washington Post brought out the
Russian investigation at a time when
President Trump is trying to get his
agenda passed I just kind of thought he
was a creep
Becky gray was in her early 20s working
at an Alabama mall when she says she
complained to a manager about Moore who
persistently tried to ask her out on a
date why don't you be honest with
yourself
why don't you look at yourself in the
mirror and come clean with what you've
done many polls show Moore's core
supporters about a third of Alabama
voters remained solidly behind him
people like Stacy Griffin he's not
guilty and I
I hardly believe what he said if you see
a big surge in voting colonists Steve
flowers writes about Alabama politics I
think that core supporter is not leading
more why they're just evangelical voters
they are so devoted to more they may not
believe the accusations or they may be
so zealous that they don't care for now
president Trump has indicated he will
not be coming to Alabama to campaign for
more but the president has made clear he
does not want mores
Democratic opponent doug jones elected
to the US Senate
when Alabama voters go to the polls two
weeks from today
all right deal two weeks and Counting
thank you very much mark